خطه فرنسيه لاجلاء مهاجرين من باريس في
مسائل اخلاء العاصمه من حوالي 3600 شخص
بلا ماوى غالبيتهم من المهاجرين الخطه
الفارسيه تاتي في اطار استعدادات عاصمه
النور لاستقبال دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه في
صيف العام المقبل تقرير لغاردن قال ان
الحكومه الفرنسيه تزعم انها تسعى الى منح
المهاجرين حياه افضل عبر نقلهم الى اقاليم
اخرى في البلاد ترى صحيفه البريطانيه ان
المهاجرين يعنون الكثير من الصعوبات في
باريس ان ملاجئ الطوارئ مقتظه تعج بهم في
حين يقضي طالبوا اللجوء ليال قاسيه في
خيام ضمن معسكرات اقيمت على الطريق
الدائري وبالقرب من ملاعب رولون غاغوسا
الشهيره حيث تجري بطوله فرنسا المفتوحه
للتنس اضحت مدرسه ملاذ لنحو 500 مهاجر
معظمهم قدم من افريقيا ونقلت صحيفه عن
المنتقدين اقتناعهم بان هدف رئيس الفرنسي
الوحيد من وراء الاجراءات الجديده هو
اخفاء ازمه الهجره عن الزوار الاجانب
الذين سيحضرون مناسبتي بطوله العالم
الركبي والعاب الاولمبيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات